Міністерство оборони Азербайджану в
середу 20 вересня опублікували відео на
якому стверджується що вірменські сили
тікають з копів нагірному карабасі на
цих відео знятих з повітря можна
побачити людей які йдуть через траншеї
раніше в середу Міністерство повідомило
що вірменські сили в карабаху погодилися
скласти зброю залишити бойові позиції та
військові пости та повністю роззброїтися
А вся зброя Та важка техніка буде
передана азербайджанській армії цитує
ройтерс Напередодні у нагірному карабасі
заявили про припинення вогню з 13-ї
години за місцевим часом Влада не
визнаної республіки повідомила що
складає зброю і виводить свої війська з
регіону Міноборони Азербайджану
підтверджує досягнення домовленостей про
припинення вогню усе це сталося через
добу після того як азербайджанська армія
почала наступ у нагірному карабасі
напередодні 19 вересня Азербайджан почав
у карабасі так звані антитерористичні
Заходи які за його словами були
розпочаті після того двоє військових і
четверо мирних жителів загинули в
результаті підриву на мінах вимога має
Азербайджану було роззброєння та
виведення вірменських військ і розпис
уряду невизнаної нагірно-арабатської
республіки
це не стало несподіванкою Оскільки ми
бачили як протягом останніх тижнів якщо
не місяців триває нарощування військ тож
Ми боялися або очікували що щось подібне
може статися будь-якою миті проте я
особливо здивований що це відбувається
під час засідання ООН поки всі
зосереджені на Україні поки весь світ
збирається в нью-йорку мати це тут на
Кавказі дивне знак що це відбувається
саме зараз це одне і інше Я думаю що між
азербайджаном розсію та Туреччиною
ймовірно була домовленість щоб запустити
певну операцію прямо зараз
азербайджанська армія оголосила про
проведення військової операції в
карабаху з метою відновлення
Конституційного ладу Єреван присутність
своїх військових у карабаху заперечує
внаслідок обстрілів загинули 32 особи у
тому числі сімерних жителів поранено
понад 200 людей заявила омбудсмен
Вірменія А наїд манасян у Вірменії
тривалий масові протести
протестувальники вимагали від
керівництва країни вжити заходів для
припинення війни та деякі експерти
наголошували що вірменські війська в
регіоні не мають сил протистояти
Азербайджану
тепер вибір стоїть дуже простий чи
перекинеться ця війна до Вірменії чи ні
вона перекинеться якщо вірменські
збройні сили зараз вступлять у біль якщо
вони будуть у відповідь зі своєї
території якось обстрілювати
азербайджанські позиції які відповідно
обстрілюють степанакерт але в такому
разі Вірменія сама зазнає втягування в
цю війну в іншому випадку якщо Вірменія
не втручатиметься то мабуть бойові дії
можуть завершитися дуже швидко тому що
ці сила які є в карабаху вірменські сили
не мають особливого потенціалу до опору
Азербайджану
український армянских сил нет особого
потенциала к сопротивлению у ЄС засудили
ескалацію та закликали Азербайджан
повернутися до діалогу про це йдеться у
заяві глави зовнішньополітичного
відомства жозепа бореля експерти
звертали увагу на повідомлення про
концентрацію азербайджанських військових
поблизу нагірного карабаху в останній
кілька тижнів А також про постачання
зброї з Ізраїлю до Азербайджану
Я думаю що це було за згодою Москви Та
анкари я припускав що цю відмажку мали
дати Минулого тижня але це сталося зараз
я не думаю що в Азербайджані вірили у те
у що хотілося б а саме у безумовну
передачу влади йшлося про те щоб за
допомогою покрокової тактики забрати
регіон під свій вплив це тривало багато
місяців і тепер пішло вхід вичавлювання
людей це результат системних підготовок
до цього і справа дійшла до якоїсь точки
де було отримано добро на прихід до
наступної
зустрічі
на допомогу врегулюванні конфлікту що
спалахнув закликав Прем'єр Вірменії
нікол пашинян при чому чекав він на неї
судячи з його заяви зокрема від
Російської сторони чи є миротворці
розміщені в нагірному карабаху
фактично Азербайджан розпочав наземну
операцію спрямовану на етнічне чищення
вірменирного
карабахун
який йдеться у заяві МЗС Вірменії
по-перше російський миротворчі сили
мають вжити заходів по-друге ми очікуємо
що Рада Безпеки ООН також вживатиме
відповідних заходів
багато експертів неодноразово звертали
увагу на похолодання у відносинах Москви
та Єревану і навіть вбачали у діях
Вірменії розворот від Росії а в діях
Росії бажання помститися союзнику за
зраду Кремль наполягає що зберігає з
вірменією партнерські відносини
президент Туреччини реджата її пердоган
у своїй промові перед генасом блеєю ООН
також послався на суверенітет
Азербайджану і буквально висловив свою
підтримку діям Баку в день проведення
так званих антитерористичних заходів у
нагірному карабаху який призвели до
загибелі понад 30 осіб
як зараз усі визнають Карабах і
територію Азербайджану тому жодного
іншого статусу не може бути диктовано
наша головна мета повинна полягати в
тому щоб усі включаючи вірмен жили мирно
пліч-о-пліч на азербайджанських землях
Азербайджан топтан борисів чи не Яніна я
сама з Анжеліки де фемізон
Ми підтримуємо кроки які робиться з
Азербайджан і дій під гаслом однієї
держави двох народів для захисту своєї
територіальної цілісності
[музика]
А у Міноборони Азербайджану заявляли що
дії Баку були відповіддю на провокацію з
боку Вірменії
Ми спостерігали такі кроки як приведення
підрозділів у високий рівень бойової
готовності створення додаткових
підрозділів для мобілізації посилення
розвідки у бік азербайджанської армії
проникнення в глибину наших позицій та
повторне мінування розмінованих
територій а також цивільних шляхів з
метою терористичної провокації
однак штефан-майстер порівнюючи ризики
та можливості сторін скептично ставиться
до подібних заяв абсолютно
потрібен був привід для нападу Ну я маю
на увазі що ні вірмени нагірного
карабаху ні є риба не в змозі
протистояти Баку у військовому
відношенню тому було б безглуздо так би
мовити їх провокувати і це теж типовий
засіб Росії та пострадянського простору
звинувачувати опонента в тому що робите
Ви самі провокуєте щоб виправдати напад
про ні вірменських формувань у карабасі
та виведення військових за словами
Азербайджану відбувається в координації
з російськими миротворцями однак
говорити про повну де ескалацію
конфлікту поки що зарано